talk Gamescom now because in the past 24
hours we've had a Microsoft press
conference a Sony press conference uh
big to-dos over there in Germany if you
watched we had them live on the site as
well as live blog and a bunch of uh
articles related to them if you want to
read more on those about stuff we're
going to talk about now so just listen
up like reading is done man come on
we're talking about it here done let's
talk about Microsoft's press conference
uh did you guys did you guys wake up too
early in your in your life watch
absolutely not so you've you've read
about it you've heard about it
presumably one of the things you've
heard about rise of T the Tomb Raider is
let's see if I can word this right uh
holiday 2015 exclusively on Xbox yeah
right yeah so a that's big that that's
exclusively on Xbox but for what period
of time is the big question right how
much value does that have uh well it's a
holiday season so you know that they're
asking you know they're asking people
that if you want it for Christmas this
year this is the one platform you can
get it on or two you know two they on
Xbox
they maybe there could be a 360 version
you'd like to think that at some point
they'll stop making Xbox 360 games and
start making them for the new platforms
instead of these like these old
dinosaurs yeah like straddling the line
and making no one happy um yeah it's you
know I feel like you know hey this this
is just like do you want to play Rise of
the Tomb Raider Definitive Edition PS4
mid 2016 y PC effect Delux yeah there's
plenty of people that don't want to wait
that long I mean I know that I like the
first one quite a bit and so yeah I'll
just buy it on Xbox so I think it's a
pretty good get for them yeah is it a
system seller does it tip the needle I
don't think it's that like killer app or
anything like that but it's it was a
really good game that last every little
bit helps when it comes to that stuff
you know it's like Sony did their
Destiny stuff and you know it's like
it's everyone's got their own little
bits here and there first on but this is
I mean this is a major Sequel and a
major franchise uh you know it's
certainly bigger than like you got some
better pauldrons in Diablo if you got
the PlayStation version or whatever it
is it's your last of us clickers that
you can fight as a oos to right yeah
yeah so you know it's that's that's a
big deal uh I don't know it's hard for
me to like get too built up about it
because I just didn't get into that last
Tomb Raider game that much so I'm with
Dan that thing was awesome it was
awesome and then the ending kind of just
turned me because you guys are creeps
and you're all you bought into the whole
thing of like yeah they want they want
you to want to protect
Lara I actually like the Island's alive
[__] little CU I like do those
environmental deaths and then it's like
oh God I actually really don't want to
die they do a good job with those deaths
between that like that and dead space I
think does the best just jarring like oh
God that's
terrible thinks we're like into snuff
films now Dan yeah I we'll talk about
that off camera but cool yeah that's a
bonus segment so there you go the sequel
to 8 mm will be available exclusively on
the Xbox one Speaking of Rise of the
Tomb Raider colon kill them machine kill
them all oh God what dark dark uh
speaking of exclusive to Xbox one we got
a look at Quantum break some new we saw
the gameplay basically for the first
time and hey it's a third person shooter
finally can I hide behind stuff yes
great wait but there needs to be more
than me just popping dudes in the head
is there some kind of weird mechanic
that involves that like uh polygonal
time fractalization thing if I miss a
head shot can I roll it back to get it
right in the next time what about a
confusing TV show that no one seems to
know how it works does it have that yes
no we're not even going to talk about
that this time around just you get pop
dudes no it's it's good that they're
finally showing this as a game I know
like when they when they shut down that
La Studio people were like what does
this mean for Quantum break and they're
like nothing don't worry cool it it's
fun it's fine it's fun it's gonna be a
game um yeah so you know it's like it's
the next game from these guys and and
that's that's exciting they've they've
done some some amazing work so hopefully
this will pan out I mean I think it
looks nice but yeah at some point if
you're like yeah we're by the way all
this work is going into a cover shooter
yeah yeah I mean we all said Allan Wake
had its sort of shooting mechanics but
with the flashlight and you know there's
so is this you know is the the stuff we
see here in a little bit is it that is
that going to be a a gimmick that's
interesting that like strings you
between the in the the like more
compelling narrative connections or
Mysteries uh these I don't know it's
tentatively excited about it because I
think it's a nice looking game but you
know like it's kind of too early to tell
did you like alen wake not especially I
didn't either so that's why I'm kind of
hesitant on this one yeah I think we're
going to see some weird stuff happening
here but the rest of the Microsoft press
conference I don't know if anything he's
hid behind something and shooting people
you're right that is weird no but Jeff
the the cans are moving you see and then
he's running away from a grenade uh
because basically at any time he runs
time freezes Bo you got this little like
yellow line in the corner depleting
whenever he does that kind of thing yeah
I mean you know the time you know I
never want to run out of that time
rewinded potion yeah as long as I can
use that yeah as long as we can talk
about what soldja boy said about braid
for another couple of years uh then yes
please give me more time more games time
there's no point to this game you just
you just shoot yeah and then you're R
time it's like Mario for people who like
to get high as he said yes yeah this is
like a Gears of War for people who like
to get high I thought Gears of War was
Gears of War for people who like to get
high well you know it's a big
demographic there's a lot of there's a
lot of money there it's Denver it's
legal there the rest of uh Microsoft's
press conference I mean they talked a
lot they did kind of the what I think of
as the Sony thing beating that Indie
drum that id8 Xbox thing saying we've
got you know Space Engineers Goat
Simulator all coming first on Xbox one
uh did you guys get any general
impressions of how the you know totally
how the conference went how it worked
out for Microsoft what their message was
I think you know I think they got some
stuff that got people talking you know
they they also got out there and talked
about you know it's like nothing that
you would get up on stage and get all
sexy about but like the DLNA support for
media playback and you know kind of
getting that stuff on the box finally
they put out a codec list that actually
supports all the codecs you'd wanted to
support unlike the 360 which didn't so
maybe less transcoding for people in the
future very exciting word you just said
see video files all right I know what
those is you need to download The Real
Player and install that then you can
watch real video files get right that
yellow the purple EXA it's right there
just get close to yourit it's fun
fantastic Sony now let's talk about that
one I I did get to watch the mostly the
entirety of they rolled a bunch of
trailers yeah yeah except for the parts
that broke yep yeah there were some
broken parts at least the camera work
was a little steadier this year last
year's like who devil mayare attitude uh
the one of the highlights for me was
like during that you know the weird
talkie part where they just talk about
features and don't show cool stuff but
actually some of the features are kind
of cool PlayStation Now PlayStation TV
blah blah blah yeah the share play was
sort of the one they talked about I
think they kind of announced it yeah it
was one of the kind of initial things
they talked about with the console and
then it wasn't it was one of the many
features that weren't there at launch
even though they talked about it so
they're they're kind of getting ready to
make good on that so as I understand it
it's uh local games that you can play
local co-op like like you and a buddy on
the couch if you can play those online
with like if Dan and I want to play
Child of Light together and I'm you know
the the princess adventuring around and
you're my little igniculus Firefly buddy
if you do if you don't have the game we
can just we can connect online you can
play as that dude in my game okay I read
that straight from a Sony blog
post I think that you know the other
thing is that this will be kind of like
past the controller typee stuff when
they talked about this feature
originally it was idea of like you're at
a spot in a game you're stuck and you
can hand control of the game over to
someone else and they can get past that
spot for you uh so this sounds like it
will be using something similar to
PlayStation now like a video streaming
because they're saying you know the
person doesn't need to own the game
right so you know it'd be like you over
a video stream you'll be able to invite
them to take control via video and play
the game for a while and then that'll
also theoretically work for games that
you want to play local co-op in that
that's where it gets a little shaky for
me cuz it's like well developers
couldn't be bothered to do the work to
make it online for realsies huh right
here you go why make online local
specifically there for people that don't
own the game so it could be like you
know if my sister's having a you a
really tough time with a boss fight in
the game you know she could have me just
kind of dial in I guess and take over
for a little bit Yeah I wonder how that
works with signing in and trophies and
things like that like if you're
controlling someone else's game if that
I I don't know do you get the the Puppet
Master trophy for you know helped that
helped someone through it so far see
that but the other example they gave was
TowerFall Ascension uh which and they
the example was specifically like
cooperatively take on a challenge quest
right so I've got TowerFall I want to
beat this Quest Jeff comes in to help me
out but TowerFall essenti is a local
competitive game as well so like can you
and I also just duel I'm going to say
probably I I my what I took away from
the press conference and and just kind
of talking about that feature you know
over time as they they've kind of talked
about it and not talked about it is that
yeah it is just kind of we could justum
jump in and play whatever we want cuz
it'll be basically kind of I think the
theory is that it'll be just translating
controller inputs that are coming in
over the network to controller inputs
that would be happening locally uh so at
some point you start to actually
extrapolate that out and think about
consumer grade Broadband connections and
bandwidth concerns and stuff like that
like PlayStation Now is running on
gigantic insane servers and you know is
is not just like you were there all the
time yeah and you know on live and
certainly stuff like that and doing a
TowerFall Ascension versus like an NBA
2K yeah and you you think about
TowerFall Ascension and the reason why
it doesn't have online multiplayer is
kind of twofold of it being a small team
that might not be able to make that work
happen but also like that theory of like
you know the latency is too much yeah
you need that sharpness imagine taking
that latency and then adding to it an
entirety entire video stream that
doesn't sound like it'd be a fun
experience I don't know so I I feel like
that's going to be one of those things
that will work better for some games
than others and and who knows how
they'll like compensate for some of that
stuff or even like for Far Far Cry 4 how
they what was that whole thing with with
the 10 Keys yeah they they announced
that back at E3 they did and then they
said what only two hours then back at E3
they did say it was like a Time limited
thing so yeah you'll be able to invite
up to 10 people separately um to
download some version of the game uh and
then they'll be able to play with you
for two hours that to me just seems like
a pre-order thing waiting to happen of
just like hey convert this download you
already downloaded into the real thing
yep here's
your progress through yeah it just seems
like them building an upsell
opportunity is pretty smart and I think
two hours of plan Co-op is a good amount
of time to decide whether or not you
like a game enough to drop 60 bucks so
yeah I think it's really smart uh what
did you guys think about the cardboard
box showing theal Gear Solid situation
that was absurd so stupid so great I
love it's just like hey you know we
talked about the cardboard box before
but look man we really want to get into
the nuances we haven't told you
everything about this cardboard box it's
not just a box we also put a pinup on it
and our s the soldiers you go up against
are like what so hard up that they are
like man there is a picture of a sexy
lady over here I got to run up on ity
tun all
over if you think about it that's been
Theo of metal gear for some time now
with the the horn magazines other weird
stuff they've done over time like the
the soldiers are
horn dogs and it's creep compl idiots
and complete
idiots for this I I like that they have
added a bunch of features to the
cardboard box I guess why not cardboard
cardboard Metal Gear is so stupid Metal
Gear is so
stupid I love that I love that it is
stupid but but also trying to be super
serious right yeah and then it's just
like this weird preachy you know War
tale and then here I am hiding in a car
real time 24-hour day cycle like at some
point yeah exactly someone needs to just
save save Kojima from himself
God there's the later one where the box
is on the ground he just crawls out the
side the dude has I think that's this
one here got peripheral vision well he's
distracted there's a sexy lady on it oh
my good she she's in a bed of flowers
What's happen he dropped his gun I think
I also love how much someone really
thought about that like different you
know it's like an origami box like
different art be in different folds I
like how it's 1984 and he's got a PS4
box on his head like everything got be
just for the trailer that's that's
probably I would put they do someu yeah
Metal Gear is really stupid it always
has been it's been stupid in ways that
like make me super angry at times but
sometimes it's stupid in the exact right
way that's closer to the exact right way
they had issues of Game Informer in
Middle Gear 3 which was set in the 60s
so they could have a PS4 box on it said
in 1984 so it could be can in the Stupid
Stupid World of metal gear the best all
right last game I want to talk about out
of the Sony press conference they
finished it up uh Michelle anel's new
team wild sheep this game wild uh which
just basically showed a bunch of people
running around and then a bunch of
animals running around and they said you
can play as those animals did you guys
get anything more solid out of this I
liked it because you ever play tale of
the sun on PlayStation one no I saw you
tweet about that and I looked it up and
I had no idea what's going on it is a
fantastic weird game and this just
reminds a lot of way super weird game so
great and this looks like a Next
Generation uh tale of the Sun so I think
the the weird part was seeing Andel come
out and like not be there with Ubisoft
and stuff so I guess like I I don't know
maybe did you track this down at all
apparently he is still with Ubisoft but
also doing this separately really I
don't know like that's that was the the
talk that we got uh that that came our
way VIA Twitter as this was happening
that I I didn't actually go verify but
that just seems ridiculous at some point
sounds like this is strictly a side
project for him it's amazing that they
would let him do that maybe that was the
the compromise of just like look man
we're never going to let you make beond
good evil to why don't you just stop and
he's like well I want to go make my
weird game about bow and arrow hunters
and you can play as a sheep GI lady uh
and and they asked him they said can you
make it so you can climb up Towers to
reveal more of the world and he's like
no he said well then it can't be a
Ubisoft game
yeah and then at that point he had to go
out on his own to make it so but then
still they're like we might still need
you to come in and like reinvent Rayman
to everyone someone's going to have to
do it again you know we've made two of
these we're keeping dibs on you some way
uh super weird it's weird I mean there's
a tree there's a giant tree giant lady a
big tree lady I'm down there FES in it
earlier I don't know bors Running With
Wolves and any game that lets me play as
an animal I am way down with because I
don't I think video games you know have
that power to take us outside I would
rather have a Tokyo Jungle too really
yeah you want to play
those like hollowed eyed Pomeranians
like looking at you from their Dark
Souls those things freak me out hey it
was a rough world man that's true all
right guys uh that's Gamescom news for
today but of course Gamescom is running
all week and it's a huge show so we out
stories posting all the time for that
we've got a team over there uh you guys
doing any Gamescom related stuff no it's
not that huge of a [__] all well tell us
like you're lying about it it's not they
they already announced they already
announced the Sierra stuff like Geometry
Wars is coming but cake Bread's not
involved so who cares every single day
we'll have breaking news on
g.com that you will not want to miss
Kano is in Mortal
Kombat